I'm Patrick made evident today I wanted
to share with you probably one of the
most humiliating and embarrassing times
of my life I could laugh about it today
but it wasn't funny when it was taking
place and this was back then back in
2002 and the reason why we're on this
corner here we're currently right now on
the Reseda and Nordhoff right behind me
CSUN Cal State University in North Korea
just a block away they got some 20,000
students that go there regularly and
this is one of the busiest streets in
the valley can think about as you can
tell a lot of cars will come by you hear
a lot of noise background noise but back
in 2001 when I got started with Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter and I decided to
leave to another firm in Oh to April of
oh - I hit rock bottom financially when
I went to the new firm I did not know
that it was going to take several months
for me to get my licenses transferred
because it was the worst time in the
financial industry and nobody cared
about buying any kind of stocks mutual
funds anything related related to the
stock market it was just not a good time
to be in this business it was a very
very difficult time to be in a business
and I remember when I went to the new
firm here's what I didn't know I didn't
know that financial industry worked and
I wanted to be in a long term cuz I fell
in love with the business we help a lot
of people out there's a big impact
you're making in people's lives it's
something that most people don't know a
lot about they need help to learn about
how money works so I knew that's what I
wanted to do a long term and I knew was
going to be difficult for the first
couple of years starting off my business
so I went back to Bally's very very
embarrassed in time I went back to
Bally's to ask them for a job and I'll
never forget they offer me the lowest
job during that time I was 22 years old
they gave me a morning manager position
which means you got to open up the club
at 4 o'clock in the morning the only
reason they tell you manager because
you're managing the opening of the club
that's not that impressive
of a position it sounds good but it's
not the most you know impressive
position you have and nobody buys
memberships at 7 o'clock in the morning
people are working right so I got
minimum wage which was $800 a month
after taxes I barely kept anything to
myself and I needed to make more money
and so I had $200 left on my credit card
I was 14 I KN that but my dad was in a
hospital
- Oh financially was at the UCLA Medical
Center and we had no money we literally
had nothing to our name and so I went to
downtown LA with one of my buddies
brothers we went to downtown LA and we
bought a hundred shirts at $2 a pod and
we came over here on this corner and we
would park my truck backwards we would
open up the window hang three shirts and
we would sell the shirts one or 15 - 420
the profit margin was 8 to 13 dollars
but we had to go to downtown to pick up
the shirts and we'd come out here
instead why am I telling this story
because my dad is a man with surprises
so a few months ago he came out of
nowhere and he said Patrick I have these
shirts that you used to sell I kept
three of them and I wanted to give it to
you so why'd you wait 10 years he said
well they were not that meaningful all
these years but I know right now
probably got a big meaning to you and I
said okay let me look at him here the
three shirts I want to share with you
I'm going to show you my best seller as
well so the first one was we will be
more strongly United okay the second one
was wanted Osama bin Laden the most
dangerous man in the world obviously
after 9/11 he was hated for obvious
reasons and then the best seller was
this college student used to love buying
this sure don't ask me why maybe because
it says Osama yo mama but it was the
hottest shirt we had during that time
and it was selling like hotcakes left
and right you know what this did it help
me make some money to get by during that
time it helped me get by by getting my
own business and eventually allowed me
to survive the first two years of being
involved in the financial industry I
think too many times I see people the
moment they hit a wall or something
happens to them and they sell you know
what this is why I can't do this
business this is why this is too
difficult for me there's no way in the
world I could do it nobody knows my
situation no one knows what kind of
struggles I'm going through financially
for every hundred stories like that
there is one story of somebody who
overcoming I'm not the only person there
are hundreds of thousands of people who
overcome struggles and challenges and
they become inspiration to many other
people who do the same as well and
eventually things changed it picked up
business changed I ended up traveling
all over the world the business ended up
giving me an incredible life it did not
give me an opportunity do things for my
dad I never thought I could do and but
when I sit there and I think about it
now I go back in 2002 and reminisce
April of Oh chew wasn't the funnest time
of my life it reminded me though for the
rest of my life that no matter what
happens in life you can always step up
and hustle your way out of difficult
situations if you're willing to work
hard and be creative there are many ways
to get out of bad financial situations
and anybody can do that I'm not the only
story so if you have a good story of
your hustling and getting out of a bad
financial situation I'd love to hear
about it if not go out there and hustle
go out there and bust it you're special
you can do something big with your life
I promise you but you got to make the
decision want to go out there and hustle
when everybody else wants to give up you
keep fighting it's my message to you
today and please be sure to share your
thoughts and the story of hustle on the
bottom with me
you